well you all have the the bios in the
programs but just recap a little bit GG
is working on a program at MIT that in
large part is trying to rethink the
process of developing and getting
approval for potentially life-saving
drugs so the place that I want to start
is I want to wait for a second on how
that actually works and just try to tee
up what the problems actually are I
think people might have a sense that
this is not a process that goes well
that often for both the companies and
researchers developing the drugs and
then when it turns into a policy issue
how that can go wrong too but we talk
for a second about just what the shape
of the problem is that you're trying to
address sure so the way I tend to think
about the problem is that what it's not
just a question of developing new drugs
it's really a question of how are we
going to get new better Affordable drugs
to the right patients faster and when
you frame the problem that way what you
begin to realize is that in order to
achieve that goal it involves a very
complex network of players it involves
academic researchers biotech and
pharmaceutical companies regulators
public and private payers prescribers
usually physicians and patients and
that's globally that's not just in the
US the problem that we're having is that
at the present time in the current model
all of these players are operating as
independent agents there's no
coordination across them there's very
little awareness between the right arm
and the left arm there is extremely poor
information sharing across this network
of players so I don't actually think of
it that way that
surprised me because I mean my sense is
that you sort of a usually a big
pharmaceutical company at this point
would be working on some new chemical
right and they'll go through phase 1 2
and 3 trials and and the FDA presumably
is aware that those trials are going on
and the trials get bigger and bigger and
more and more people get involved and
the data that comes up from those trials
gets shared and based on what those
results are I guess and you're smiling
like I'm horribly naive I can tell
already based on what those results are
then the FDA sort of says yes or no at
the end of that process in you I hope
you end up with a drug out in the field
that's totally wrong apparently if only
it were so linear no it doesn't quite
work that way for example you might have
a pharmaceutical company working on a
particular compound and that effort
might fail it might go to a regulatory
agency it might not be approved might
not even get to the regulatory agency
the company itself might kill off the
effort their internal results might show
that it the Quran wanted to do right but
because the particularly in the area of
failure there's so little information
sharing you may simultaneously have five
or six other companies doing the exact
same experiments at the exact same time
in parallel so the lack of coordination
and information sharing is actually
wasting resources so this is a problem
in science generally that negative
results tend not to get published but
then when there's a competitive
advantage to not publishing your
negative results I suppose it must be
that much more difficult that's exactly
right and so the need for better
information sharing to begin generating
the knowledge that we need what you find
when you look at the players across this
ecosystem I think of this as an
innovation ecosystem that all of them
have to answer really critical
benefit-risk trade-off questions whether
it's the companies saying should I
invest more money in this compound
what's the likelihood of success for
this compound or if you're looking at
the regulators and they're there try
their job is to protect the public and
they're trying to understand with a new
compound what's the the relative benefit
risk ratio here for patients how likely
is it to be helpful and how likely is it
that it might cause harm the payers are
trying to figure out should we pay for
this we have
resources what's the likelihood that
compound a the new drug is going to be
more effective than compound B which is
already on the market and by the way
would be a lot cheaper it's the same
thing for the patients and the
physicians the information that they
have to make decisions at the point of
care is based on population based data
that the regulators and the payers use
but that doesn't really help us as a
patient when a new drug comes on to the
market to say wow I wonder if I should
take this what's the likelihood that
it's actually going to be helpful to me
given my genetic makeup given the other
illnesses that I have in the other drugs
that I'm on these are questions that
simply cannot be answered today when a
drug is a new drug is approved so some
of the personal issues about what based
on my genome what reactions I'm going to
have to a given drug that's some what
we've talked about today I already but
the rest of that the sort of back at the
house process that you just laid out it
is hideously complicated obviously so so
that's what you're working on bringing
those folks together explain how your
project works in trying to cut through
some of that yeah and it will just say
one thing adjusted to bring the point
home on what the problem is is that we
are we are operating in very fragmented
ways that waste resources were failing
to generate the knowledge that we need
but when you think about who the enemy
is in the story the enemy isn't another
pharmaceutical company and the enemy
isn't another nation the enemy is the
disease the diseases that we're trying
to fight which by nature end up
operating within a highly efficient
natural ecosystem where they're
continually evolving and adapting and
develop developing resistance to the
drugs that we're throwing at them so we
have to operate at least as efficiently
as they do well let's stick to that
actually for a second because in some
what you've written you talked about
models in other countries for example
they don't do it the way the way we do
it here does that provide any insight is
there another approach that someone else
is using that we could just sort of grab
and pour it over no there's no simple
off-the-shelf solution and I think what
you find is that the different players
if you can sit down and talk with them
which we'll get to what how weird
doing what we're doing what you
understand is that that there isn't any
single player that is at fault or that's
causing the problem here that if you sit
down and understand from each player's
perspective why they do what they do and
you come to understand that the risks
and incentives that are at play within
their world they're all operating in a
pretty rational sort of a way just
trying to do their best to optimize the
outcome within their silo and I would
imagine all of them are sort of blaming
the other players too right i mean farm
to a company will sit right but farmers
are coming and say oh you know the ref
PA won't let us write do the regulator
fda says like yeah we can't you know
they want to get a drug out there to
make money off but we're trying to keep
people safe or we're trying to keep the
economy going by representing those
interests i mean they're all it's going
to be some other players there's a lot
of finger-pointing that goes on but the
beauty of working within the concept of
a global innovation ecosystem is that
you may find that in some cases for
example other regulators around the
world may not have to work in such a
complex and shall we say dysfunctional
political environment as we have on
occasion here in the US so you might
actually be able to drive some elements
of change at the level of the system by
working with other regulators that are
within a different context within a
different architecture of a health care
delivery system that allows them to try
new things as well so sometimes crisis
does drive that change the right I mean
you said that like the approval of new
HIV drugs was an example of how system
could work more efficiently and better
you can find definitely can find some
success stories there a number of
success stories that are starting to
take shape now with parts of the
ecosystem self-organizing and operating
at peak performance these are very very
often they're driven by patients not
really a surprise but we're seeing more
and more those happen and with HIV HIV
was actually a fairly spectacular
success story if you look back to the
80s and 90s and fitzy it was again it
was the patient's it was a patient
advocacy groups that conveyed to the FDA
in particular that they were willing to
tolerate a higher degree of risk and
uncertainty with new drugs in exchange
for potentially getting access to
life-saving drugs and it was that kind
of political cover
that was provided by the patients to the
regulators that allow the FDA to
actually develop a new first-ever
accelerated approval pathway which then
allowed the companies to be willing to
take more risk and they were
extraordinarily productive and
developing some new drugs which have
decreased the death rate by over
eighty-five percent now but in the u.s.
you're talking about correct what's that
in the US the death rate I mean in
places wouldn't have access to the drugs
for example this was correct but there
was a global ecosystem that did eat that
did mobilize in the story but what when
I was surprised to find recently and
looking at where we are now because we
all think that that was a terrific
success story and it was but the part
that we may not be so aware of that we
haven't wiped out the disease yet it's
continuing to evolve and to adapt
becoming resistant to these drugs in
2005 alone there were another five
million new cases of HIV AIDS that were
that were diagnosed and there are now 19
new drugs in the put in the R&D pipeline
globally so you can see even when the
eco system is operating at peak
performance it takes an enormous and
sustained effort for us to try to stay
just a step ahead of the pathogens all
right so that's a long run up so what do
you so what do you do to make to get
those kind of successes to be the rule
rather than the exception right so so
we're running I'm running a program at
MIT called new digs new digs is a kind
of funky acronym for new drug
development paradigms and what we do in
new digs is we actually I think for the
first time create a space a safe haven
environment for all these players to
come together and to talk about some of
these these issues some of the big
conundrums that we're facing that we're
having trouble fixing in this process
and get to understand each other's
perspective and actually design and test
new models the particular model that we
decided to start with is taking a look
at the challenges associated with
regulation as some of the folks at the
table last night told me that that
sounds really boring actually
but it actually is a fantastically rich
window into some of the challenges
involved with process innovation at the
level of a system the innovation system
so but I mean how does it work in
practice because it can't just be well
as long as everybody comes and sits
around the same campfire yes then we'll
all just solve the problems like what do
you what's the what's the process how
what are you guiding them to come to
well first thing that we do is we we
work with great people from all these
different players these are folks who
are really smart really progressive
change agents and they're there because
they want to drive change in the
interest of patience that's the first
thing the second thing is that we have a
fairly explicit set of guiding
principles for how we operate which are
really coming to define the culture that
we've created in this incubator
environment and so we this is this is a
safe haven place where people are not
making any formal binding decisions on
behalf of their organizations we're
coming in to explore to learn to test
it's a little bit of a skunk works like
operations so they're saying so when
they come in and say well what have we
tried it this way and then laying out a
specific programmatic changes so what
we're particularly looking at is moving
towards a new regulatory paradigm called
adaptive licensing and the way that
we're learning more about is is we've
actually been successful at doing
something that we didn't expect we were
going to be able to do that is getting
pharmaceutical companies come in and
under confidentiality agreements
actually presenting proprietary data
about products that are currently in
their rd pipeline and we have a group of
about 20 players including regulators
from the u.s. from Europe from Singapore
from Canada we have payers from the UK
private payers from the US number of
companies and we actually do simulations
live simulations of this new regulatory
model on these actual real-world
compounds to try to understand what it
might look like it because it never
looks the same twice there's not a
one-size-fits-all model but so I mean
just to try to drill into that so the
the pharmaceutical companies working on
compounds potentially the same kind of
compounds the same chemistry that the
across company and company I have gotten
over there gotten over their fear of
sharing information in a highly
competitive environment which must make
them nuts they do that anyway and
they're doing that in front of payers
and regulators who upon hearing what
they're all working on and what kind of
results they're getting then say what
like well now that we know that this is
what's going on we're going to speed up
the approval process on that one but
slow it down on the other one what's the
adaptation okay so first of all it's not
quite so simple the process of getting
the companies to present their
proprietary information that that's been
quite a process unto itself you would
think yeah so the companies initially of
course didn't really want to do this and
eventually one of the companies stepped
up to the plate did it and then who were
you allowed to mm we won't go there but
I asked and what ended up happening was
that they were proposing a particular
regulatory strategy that in the course
of the discussion that day a different
approach was identified for the research
approach or regulatory regulatory
regulatory and development strategy that
would allow patients who needed the
product a small subpopulation of those
patients to receive the product earlier
than they otherwise would have and then
there was a very systematic rigorous
post marketing strategy for how you
would learn about how that drug was
performing with that small population
but under real-world conditions not not
randomized controlled clinical trials in
the traditional sense this would involve
more real-world conditions more
real-world data that these patients
might have the benefits would be likely
to outweigh the risk but they might be
somebody who would have been excluded
from a traditional randomized controlled
clinical trial for their their closer
and closer to real kinds of patients who
would ultimately receive that product
but you have to see I mean in the vein
of what could possibly go wrong as Chris
asked earlier this morning I mean part
of the reason that the regulatory
environment that we have today exists is
because people were abusing the way that
trials of medications were conducted
part of the reason that we
do the randomized control trials on a
specific population and so that
nominally we have a better understanding
of what the side effects of drug remove
what the outcomes are the side effects
are not well tracked post-market today
that's a real a real issue with
understanding how drugs work in the
market I mean what you're proposing is a
potentially a much more confusing
environment with with less information
or at least less kind of less knowledge
about what's going on so I would say
that one of the challenges with
randomized controlled clinical trials is
you might get beautiful answers to the
wrong questions and the other point that
you're making here is yes it is kind of
complicated and so what we've learned
very clearly is that policy changes more
about more than just changing policy all
of the players in this story are going
to have to operate somewhat differently
and we're working through what that
looks like there has to be a value
proposition for everyone to be able to
operate differently and we're really
trying to understand at ground level
drill down to understand what are the
changes that would be required for every
player and and what's the value
proposition that would make it worth
their while to take the risk of doing
things differently but ultimately where
we need to get to with product
development with new drug development is
that we need to be able to more reliably
deliver value to individual patients the
doctors and the patients need to
understand which patients should receive
which products under what conditions and
in that way ultimately what hopefully
will begin to happen is that in health
care like in other industries new
technologies will begin to reduce costs
because right now it's an outlier and
new technology tends to drive costs and
that's just not going to be sustainable
let's do a couple of questions from you
folks I think they'll be Mike's coming
around yeah quick questions um so I've
done some consulting for some of the
farmers and one of the things I
suggested a couple years ago is that the
farm industry is by far the least
trusted component in the health care
industry and the given where we're going
with personalized medicine genomics
medicine they have the
it becomes the most trusted element when
they realize that the big opportunity is
to make sure that every single patient
who should be on one of their drugs is
and every single patient who should not
be on one of their vacations is not on
their medication and when they own that
distinction they will flip the trust
equation for the entire industry do you
have any thoughts on that well we're
certainly taking a look at that as we're
beginning to move towards our initial
demonstration projects looking at how
this new model might play out in the
real world and certainly those issues of
making sure the right patients are
getting it minimizing off-label use is
certainly important part of this whether
the pharmaceutical companies alone can
actually make that happen a little bit
skeptical about it certainly we want
them to care about that and understand
why that's important but I think part of
what we do is explore different roles
for different players to drive better
outcomes and we try to explore as
broadly as possible we think payers
actually could be playing a pretty
important role in this story as well but
yet those very issues and making sure
that the right people are yeah you're
not yeah and the other product the other
challenge is that you know in some of
the specialty areas particularly in
oncology off-label use is actually
really important I think we don't want
to stop the off-label use because that
kind of experimentation at ground level
by the experts is actually probably a
good thing in oncology and certainly the
patients are very willing to take
additional risk in the interest just
like with HIV of getting some life
saving saving combinations but what
we're not doing which is a horrible
problem is that we're we're we're doing
the off-label use and we're not learning
systematically from it and that's where
we're really falling short there's very
valuable knowledge in that ground level
experimentation we are simply not
capturing it in harvesting in a way that
would allow us to operate as a much more
intelligent ecosystem but on the
flipside this is a question that comes
from online
how do you make the make sure that
there's an ethical balance between
patients who are desperate for a drug
and their ability to give informed
consent because that's been one of the
major obstacles to having the patient's
drive what drugs they get yeah
absolutely i mean it's not it's not an
easy a question to solve that but i
think one thing that's important we're
certainly hearing this in some of the
talks today I mean page we need to
engage patients in a fundamentally
different way they have to be a part of
this research enterprise and the drug
delivery Enterprise in a way that
they're really not right now and and how
we engage them and and how we begin to
understand how to build in patient
preferences around risk tolerance
because not all not all patients are the
same and it's a challenging system
admittedly where regulators are
essentially having to act as the proxy
for patients right now so they're going
to take a conservative route but finding
new ways of empowering patients to be a
part of the process is absolutely
critical to get astute to operate to our
full potential as an ecosystem one last
one I like what you're saying and I
think that the patient engagement of
course is important but as an oncologist
I can tell you that the system doesn't
support the use of off-label therapies
given the price of new therapies the
patients don't understand the toxicities
much less the health literacy needed to
interpret statistics and there's the
unfortunate reality that you're most
likely i believe discussing palliative
care because unless it's adjuvant
therapy treatment with intent to cure
we're only providing months and it's not
fair to the public to be spending that
money on the ground level
experimentation I can't disagree with
that those are those are absolutely some
of the challenges that we're facing and
redesigning some of the innovation
elements but I think having the dialogue
with all the players at the table is
incredibly helpful part of the
educational process I think for all the
players as well
jeezy hers thank you very much
appreciate here